hello I'm alka Gerard representing the
global shapers Amsterdam community I'm a
scientist I'm an associate professor at
the Erasmus University of rudder down
and I study depression I'll also
consequences of childhood sexual cruise
I've been asked to experience a request
from Elaine Walters from facebook
questioning please tell us what you care
about what future direction you seek and
how you'll contribute to improving the
state of the world well as I'm a mental
health profession I care evidently about
mental health and diseases like
depression but also burn out or are
evidently linked to many things here at
the World Economic Forum for example
people sometimes are unable to work
because of a depression will burn out so
it's important to have that topic
covered here at the World Economic Forum
and at the moment we're trying with
several other scientists to put it more
on the agenda of the world economic
forum in the years to come so hopefully
we'll be successful in them thank you